I think is on the decline which is
leading to a lot of the unhappiness in
the world I believe the quickest path to
happiness is attention is the number one
asset oh hello Gary good to see
you thank you so much so much for being
here this podcast exists because of you
and it's all about teaching people how
to stand in their confidence so I'd like
to ask you uh confidence to me I love
the definition it's a Latin definition
it stands for self trust so how have you
been able to create such an amazing
trust in yourself and belief and
confidence and how did your upbringing
in your family and your mom and your
beautiful Community as a child help you
do that that's a great question first of
all thank you for having me on the
podcast love you know I think about this
a lot because I think I really do see
the world through the lens of confidence
versus insecurity and I believe most of
the pain and the hurt and the anger and
the Darkness in our Society is
completely based on insecurity I think
about it a lot I I Define it in a couple
quick ways I I think first and foremost
I do believe there's a heavy part of the
DNA that you're born with that is a
variable now when I say that I don't
mean that if somebody's born if they're
both confident not confident one is one
isn't that they can't be a different
version of themselves but I do believe
DNA is a factor I think parenting is a
major factor yes now this is where in
modern times especially the last 20
years we've lost our way I think a lot
of modern parents believe telling their
kids to great at everything leads to
confidence and I think we've
overcorrected you know we came from the
era of where your parents didn't tell
you they loved you right like the six
people talk about that and now we're in
an era where people tell you could do
anything and the kid knows they can't
and we've got to find the middle yeah
yeah my mom was incredibly influential
you know I speak about that a lot yeah
yeah and what she did well was she found
the middle you know in a world of black
and white she found the gray in a world
of blue and red in politics she found
the purple she made me feel good but
what she didn't do was manipulate Merit
when I struck out in a baseball game and
tried to say that it was the sun was in
my eye as an excuse yeah she wouldn't
support that she always knew that I
would make it but she still punished me
for bad grades yeah so she say you're
going to make it and taught me that
there wasn't ramifications for mailing
it in so in her grounding of me she was
teaching me that things have
consequences but they don't Define you
she was finding the middle beautiful the
way I think about confidence has a lot
to do with risk and executing on risk
this is why I'm very upset about eighth
place trophies I believe that we tell
everybody that games don't matter then
we're confusing them that's not how
nature works I think I have a lot of
confidence because I failed a lot yes I
got comfortable with failing I think a
lot of people struggle with confidence
because they got straight A's yeah yeah
they always were attractive they they
didn't have as much adversity in their
youth and they don't realize this is
actually very powerful I don't think
I've ever articulated this I don't think
people realize that are good at
everything in their youth that they
actually were using their fear to stay
away from things that they weren't going
to be naturally good
at yes oh my God I see a lot of kids
avoiding competition because they don't
want to lose so they get to say they're
good at everything but they're actually
just good at a couple things they don't
try everything they don't try most
things I think what I think about
confidence I think it becomes very
grounded in a relationship of losing
give me the I've never heard that give
me the La ter what's the definition for
confidence it's F and it's like confian
like in Spanish confian is Trust yes
trusting yourself and so I share that
because then I'm like you don't have to
say I'm not confident or I am I'm like
do you trust yourself do you know why I
trust myself blindly predominantly
because I know how I act when I lose
that's so good I love you you understand
yeah I don't trust myself based on when
I win that's easy I believe that there
is an
incredible incredible correlation to
one's relationship with losing and their
come confidence do you feel like that
your mom and your upbringing helped you
with the humility because I will say
when I met you in Melbourne and every
time I've seen you like [__] you're just
humble you've stayed the same person
you're kind you're caring you're loving
you take photos with people like you're
just so kind and H humble and I feel
like it's a trait that not a lot of
people have and you [__] have it do
you feel like that supported you as well
with the humility side of things you
know I appreciate you saying that and I
think humility comes from the losing I
don't think I'm special because I've
tasted losing so much and this goes back
to what I think is the ingredients of
confidence trusting
yourself is knowing you're good during
bad times I feel like I always say I'm a
wartime General like I'm at my best when
it's bad yeah yeah oh [__] that's so
good your message right is always about
the empathy and the compassion and it's
such a message that the world needs I
think it's always needed it but from
when I was following you in 2017 to now
it's like it's Amplified from from your
end which is beautiful because it's
needed have you done any like personal
work coaching therapy personal
development like to develop you the
person you Gary the man the dad the
person um and how important do you think
it is like self-development and growth I
hadn't for the majority of my life but
over the last ironically probably you
know to point six seven years and I
don't really feel overly affected on my
cont content because of this work it was
more about real stuff going on in my
life I had a come to Jesus moment in the
last five to seven years where I
realized and it's crazy because Gary ve
me it's my authentic self but in this
setting when he's doing public content
he's really good at cander I've done
therapy I've done work and it's been
predominantly around me becoming better
at cander with my closest relationships
not my public life where I'm very good
at it yeah yeah it's been very fruitful
and I feel like I'm better everything
including CEO including father and all
that oh I love that so much thank you
for sharing that I think it's so
important people don't see that behind
the scenes I think there's a fine
balance back to purple and black and
white like I love that people are being
more vulnerable today but I will say in
the growth of vulnerability we need
growth in accountability people become
very good at blaming mom and dad for all
their problems oh this all sucks because
my mom did this got it let me do the
work no no no no no no yes K you're a
big boy now stop it yeah stop it yeah
when I talk about being better at cander
I never bring up what I know to be true
about what got me there I always say
watch what I do not what I say I
Champion my parents maybe more I but I'm
a human being there's things my parents
did that I think were Mis turns miscues
I never talk about those things yeah
talk about my dad maybe not like like in
the work environment uncertain things
but not me like things he did that and
so I think more people should look at
that I think people need to look at
accountability I think people are
finally looking to be a little more
vulnerable and things of that nature but
I think accountability is on the decline
which is leading to a lot of the
unhappiness in the world I believe the
quickest path to happiness is
accountability once once you realize
that everything is your fault you
actually become happier I mean there
real [__] in the world oh for sure yeah
I'm one of them I hear you so when I
talk to my friends in private this is
less public talk or acquaintances or
business people if they ever like you
know I'm so out there people feel
comfortable with the way I roll I get
into some deep ass combos yeah I say to
them all the time because I can't relate
it's very hard to relate with somebody
who's had an extreme thing happen but I
do say this to them every time no matter
how I mean tears of my eyes for hearing
their story
I will still say because I feel
responsible for it hey just to remind
you if anybody on Earth with the same
exact circumstances as you has ever done
the work to get to a content and happy
place well then you can too because a
lot of people use their damage or their
negative story as an excuse to never
evolve that's exactly why this podcast
exists because I had a [__] up life
sexually abused foster care my dad
kidnapped me my husband died broke my
back yeah let let's just let just I'm
sorry to interrupt I just want everyone
who's listening to
this you just rattled off four
things that if 90% 80% 70% of the
audience had one of those things happen
yeah my grandmother may she rest in
peace Esther brought up being a widow
every day of her life when I got older I
tried to explain to him like Grandma
like I get it but you can't use that
you've been wiow
as an excuse for every single thing you
do because unfortunately hundreds of
millions of people in the test of time
have been widowed yeah we gotta move it
you gotta move it not for your not for
anyone but yourself yeah and we can
exactly before you start moving it you
know how people say no no Sally you got
to do this for your kids [__] that no
[__] that yeah 100 per. Sally you got to
do this for you and once you do it for
you then it will happen for the kids
exactly I love that that's my favorite
video like hello I have a million but
that video that's pinned on your
Instagram with that lady that's like how
do I become more confident because
obviously I talk about this and I'm just
like you need a model like you they're
going to watch who you're being not what
you say they don't listen to what we say
it's the best message for kids 100% I
love you and thank you so much thank you
thank you take
[Music]
care